Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Taco Bell in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in India, our typical
tacos come in orders of one;
two, in a two-taco meal
with fries and a drink;
three, taco-trio combo,
which comes with nachos and a drink;
or, on weekends, they have a special offer
where you can get eight tacos
in their weekend taco party extravaga --
what's it called?
Taco, taco, t --
Eight weekend party pack taco ...
Eight-taco weekend party pack!
Have a party with your friends.
Only if there are eight of them
and they all are OK with
having just one taco.
In the US, our standard Taco Bell tacos
come in orders of one,
three with a drink,
and the 12-taco box.
12 tacos, one box.
How you doing?
Here in India, our classic
burrito is 16.5 centimeters,
or 6.5 inches.
Our US burrito is 5 inches across.
In terms of girth -- this is
the first time I've measured
the girth of anything, promise.
7 inches.
Joe: Also about 5 inches.
And that's what matters most.
OK, now to measure the weight
of our classic burrito.
Damn!
This is a big boy.
291 grams.
Joe: 185 grams.
Our classic quesadilla
is just shy of 11 inches.
Joe: 10 inches.
And as for weight, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And it weighs 174 grams.
Joe: 202 grams.
At an Indian Taco Bell, the
largest item we have on our menu
is the aforementioned
weekend eight-taco party
picnic popping what
the f--- is this thing?
Eight-taco weekend party
pack, and it's always a party.
So, the vegetarian version is 499 rupees,
and the non-vegetarian
version is 599 rupees.
In the US, our biggest menu item
is the supreme variety taco party pack.
It is 12 supreme tacos,
and it runs $21.99,
or 1,751.65 Indian rupee.
Here's everything you'll
find at a Taco Bell in India
that you will not find in the US.
And here is everything at a US Taco Bell
you can't find in India.
Let's taco about it.
Here in India, all of the
tacos have a vegetarian option.
It's because even though
India is a primarily
non-vegetarian country,
we have a huge population of vegetarians
or people who have different preferences
of what kind of meat they like to eat.
And so it's great for most
of these fast-food chains
to have a lot of veg options.
All of them have the option
of either pinto beans,
fajita veggies, or Mexican paneer,
and they're also in
increasing order of spice.
The cheesy double-decker taco.
Honestly, I actually
really like this taco.
I know it's sacrilege for some people
to eat a soft-shell and a
hard-shell taco together,
but when you parcel this stuff
and get it delivered to you,
both the tacos become soft shell.
Really yum.
All right, the next taco I'm
going to eat is a crunchy taco,
plain and simple. It's
got pinto beans in it.
[sighs] It's unfair to
dis on a crunchy taco
after you've ordered it from
a restaurant that's far away,
because look at this.
It's become soggy already.
So I'm going to be gentle
on my criticism of this.
But you, you soft-shell
tacos are getting it, huh?
There's still some decent crunch to it.
Here in India, pinto beans
are what we call rajma,
and they're a staple.
We f---ing love our rajma.
So it's a perfect match
to put them in a taco.
Next up, another crunchy taco.
This one is the Mexican paneer.
Now, paneer, if you're
unaware, is cottage cheese.
We make it all over here in India.
We basically curdle milk,
add some sort of fruit
or vegetable acid to it,
like lemon juice,
and you get cottage
cheese, which is paneer.
I'm curious to know
what makes this Mexican.
Paneer is one of the most
popular things you'll find
in India at any restaurant.
This paneer tastes chalky,
like most processed paneer
that you'd store in a freezer would.
If you prefer your paneer chunky,
you might enjoy this.
Me, not so much.
Now on to the soft-shell tacos.
This one is Mexican paneer,
the same thing I just had.
This Mexican paneer is
a little bit more spicy.
My favorite thing about tacos is that
not every bite is uniform,
so you get a lot of
different textures and
flavors in each bite you take,
and I guess that's proving
its point over here.
OK, so the next one we're going to try
is a soft taco with fajita veggies inside.
I'm opting out of the fajita veggies
as a filling in general.
And finally we have
our last veggie option,
which is a veggie fiesta,
which has tater tots.
Win. That's a win.
If I was going to Taco Bell
and had to order a veggie
taco for some reason,
my option would be a
crunchy pinto bean taco.
And now for our non-vegetarian tacos.
Please note that all of
the meat in our tacos
is chicken and not beef.
This is because we have a
huge percentage of Hindus
here in India, and they do not eat beef.
This makes all of our
non-veg tacos exclusives!
Because, yes, in the US
you can substitute your beef for chicken,
but it's not on the
official menu, all right?
It's a modification,
which means these are
more exclusives to India.
OK, so you have two options of filling,
either Mexican chicken or grilled chicken.
We're starting off with a
grilled-chicken crunchy taco,
which has severely disintegrated.
Not bad. This is also kind of the test
of Taco Bell's structural integrity.
Pretty good.
That's a win from me. What
else do you want, Taco Bell?
This taco, though, has seen better times.
It kind of reminds me of a rajma chawal.
And when you're chewing on a rajma chawal,
that's how soft the chicken is.
There are a lot of
comparisons you can make
with Mexican and Indian food.
We have something exactly
like this in India.
It's called a chapati, and
it's made out of wheat.
The tortillas in Mexico are
typically made with corn.
The one in Taco Bell is made out of maida,
which is all-purpose flour.
I can't speak for Mexican cuisine,
but there's definitely a lot
of Indian flavors in this.
This is actually a soft
grilled-chicken taco,
and I can wholeheartedly
say worst of the bunch.
Don't get this one.
A cheese double-decker taco
with grilled chicken again.
Come on, man. I wanted the Mexican one.
But the hard-shell taco
is disintegrating into a soft-shell taco.
It's nothing special.
Chicken fiesta taco.
Oh, my God!
I didn't expect that at all.
I've just been chewing
for so long. I'm so tired.
Oh, damn. The aftertaste
of this is really good.
There's a lot of nice spice to it.
Now we have a very special taco.
As you can see, this one is still wrapped,
because I've never seen this in my life.
It's called a naked chicken taco.
Pause for a moment.
What do you think that means?
Oh,
my
God.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the naked chicken taco.
Crew: Whoo! [applauding]
Genuinely feels like
I just undressed food.
So, there's no chicken filling inside it
because the chicken is the taco!
That's right. That's how far
we have come as the human race.
We have taken this bird and
turned it into a freaking
pancake and folded it over cheese!
Your scientists were too
busy trying to figure out
whether they could do it.
They didn't stop to think
whether they should do it.
I think that might be one
of the worst things I've had
on this show.
Oh, God. Oh, God.
I'm gonna be honest, it actually
looks pretty good to me.
That reminds me of the KFC double down,
which I did actually enjoy. I'd try it.
Starting off, soft taco
and soft Taco Supreme,
which is beef.
Flimsiest thing in the world.
Ew!
This stuff is, oh, this stuff
is sweating already. Ugh.
So, I don't know how many
vegetarians are watching now,
but ... look at what you're missing?
I think I just created a few vegetarians.
I mean, I like how they taste,
but, I mean, Taco Bell's got
so much fun stuff on the menu.
What are you doing eating regular tacos?
Like, get out of here.
Crunchy taco, which we saw earlier.
Fantastic.
A little more stuff in it,
the beef Supreme Taco.
They really load it up with the veggies.
India. India. India!
Look at me.
This is my favorite thing
in the Taco Bell menu.
I sing its praises at every
Taco Bell "Food Wars."
It is the nacho cheese
Doritos locos tacos.
Some genius somewhere
connected Taco Bell and Doritos
to make a hard-shell taco that
is, in fact, a Doritos shell.
Mm.
Comes in standard and, of course, supreme.
This, I've been looking
forward to this all day.
It's burrito time, baby!
I've gotten a Mexican paneer version here
as well as a pinto beans version.
I think I'll go with the pinto beans one.
By the way, this tray is all
of the vegetarian burritos,
and this is the non-vegetarian tray.
Happy baby.
India has a lot of roll culture.
We have kati rolls, we have Kolkata rolls,
we also have shawarmas,
which we are a huge fan of.
Most Indians, this
basically will feel like
you took rajma rice and you
shoved it inside a maida roti.
I think I'd go with a taco over this.
Next up, we have tikka masala.
But, I found this out recently,
it was actually invented by the British.
So, clearly inspired by
India, but invented by them.
Another thing that the
British took from us
that we haven't been paid back for.
We have a flavor here
which is called achari,
and it's basically like a pickle.
This is more achari than
chicken-tikka-masala-y.
Also, I would be lying if I
didn't admit that, Taco Bell,
it's already doing its thing
to my digestive system.
Taco Bell is notorious for
making you go to the bathroom.
Zoom in to my stomach
right now and just listen
to the noises, and
let's get a translation.
[farting]
♪ Oh, my God ♪
And now for Sriracha veg burrito.
It's now running the risk
of offending three different cultures.
I don't normally eat a
burrito by ripping it in half.
Actually, that sounds awesome.
We should do that more often.
Like, a double-handed --
don't clip that.
Hm. You can skip it.
We have the seven-layer burrito.
This one tastes like all
of these put together.
And we have one last veg wrap.
Ah, guys, I can't do this.
It's the same thing!
It's just tater tots, that same filling.
I bow down in defeat, Taco Bell.
You have vanquished me.
Moving on to the non-vegetarian burritos,
and we're hoping some of these
are a little more
distinct from the others.
All right, we have a classic
Mexican chicken burrito.
This is so bad.
This is damn bad.
Let's just say I'm glad
you didn't call yourself
burrito bowl.
Next up, tikka masala, but now in non-veg.
["Piano Man" harmonica playing]
This is actually quite good!
This one doesn't taste as dry
as the other ones I've had.
And, of course, we have the seven-layer
non-vegetarian burrito.
Instead of paneer, we
have grilled chicken.
Let's just do the slap test again.
Oof.
Yeah, you could really hurt somebody
with the seven-layer one.
OK, we have one last burrito, which is --
wait, what is this?
This is not -- why have you done this?
This burrito looks like the love child
of all other burritos over here.
These burritos are definitely
related, and this is
the product of incest.
[baby cries]
Wow, it's actually not that bad.
Honestly, out of all of these,
I'd prefer to finish this one
because it's just smaller.
The pain will end faster.
Burritos.
Might not be visually the most exciting
part of the video, but please don't leave.
Maybe just open some clips
of "Family Guy" next to it,
so you can watch that and
this like you're on TikTok.
The double steak grilled cheese burrito
and the spicy double steak
grilled cheese burrito.
And, right, it's grilled
cheese 'cause they
grill it shut with cheese.
Genius idea.
Yeah! Look at that, it
has jalapeños on it.
Oh, that's fantastic.
That's a really great idea.
Oh. Yeah, this rules.
A beefy quesarito.
When these things cool off, though,
it's just a lot of cheese in there.
Oh, and it has rice in it.
Well, burritos have rice,
I don't know why I'm so surprised by that.
Rice in a burrito?!
Same thing but with black beans.
I mean, it's already kind of
dripping out there already.
Grilled No. 1, beans and
cheese in there, you see that?
And the red is those chips.
They put those crispy chips in there.
Five-layer burrito.
It used to be seven-layer.
Took out two layers and added a beefy one
for some weird reason.
I assure you there's five
layers and beef inside this.
No, I'm not doing that. I'm not
some weird fetish that on the internet
that I'm not aware of,
slapping faces with burritos.
Burrito Supreme.
Look, it's so much different
from the last thing we
were just looking at.
But that one's just like ...
"CK," Chipotle chicken.
Yeah, chipotle mayo's legit.
I got an extra one, if anyone wants it.
Go ahead and comment below,
and I'll mail it to you.
Beefy melt.
Beef and melted cheese.
I can't believe it!
Together at last!
I mean, it tastes like all the other ones.
Feel like we could pare
this menu down a little bit.
Last and not least, cheesy bean and rice.
Now for India's specialities.
I am excited for the diversity.
That's all I'll say.
Very representative of our country.
Let's start off with the chalupa.
The humble chalupa
is nice.
If you guys are at home wondering
what the difference between a
normal taco and a chalupa is,
you should Google it.
What is this, an education show?
I'm just here to eat, man.
For my Indian brethren,
it's kind of the difference
between a chapati and a patuda.
They actually fry it a little bit.
Mm, mm, mm!
But that was a very
horrible place to bite,
because I only got chicken.
I have a soft spot for the
chalupa, and it gets my approval.
We have the vegstar wrap.
Voilà.
So inventive. Let's take a
burrito but make it flat.
Oh, wow.
Don't make me eat this, Insider, please.
Ugh!
I'm coming from a country
where we're used to eating
something like this, a chapati,
with a sabzi on the side,
which is a curry which has vegetables
and fresh paneer and maybe some chicken.
So to eat something like this
just feels not even subpar,
it just feels wrong.
I'm actually curious to know
if any Mexicans watching this video
can let me know in the comments
whether you feel like
Taco Bell has done justice
to representing your cuisine in any way.
Next up, we have a chickstar.
Round of applause.
[crickets chirping]
I'm just going to keep this
UFO of man's worst
accomplishment over here.
Quesadilla, fajita veg.
Very thin.
Curious to know how they have fit
a lot of fajita veggies into it.
They haven't.
How do people do this?
My God. I just realized,
Joe is insane.
How have you eaten so much Taco Bell, Joe?
Yeah, I'm insane.
I lost my mind somewhere
during the Japan season.
Oh well.
And it's strange, 'cause
I'm still an intern.
We're doing rice bowls now.
Ugh!
Yeah, it looks really good
if it was abstract art in a museum
about 20 meters away from your eyeballs.
But when you come close
and then you're faced
with the proposition of eating it,
ugh!
I can feel my body rejecting this.
Otherwise, it's fine.
I mean, it's just very average.
It's just a normal rice bowl.
We have the same thing, another rice bowl,
but this time it's got some
grilled chicken in there.
That was really good.
This feels like the safest bet.
Ah! I don't know what anything is still.
So let's go through it together.
The first thing,
this is either a black bean
chalupa or a dirty diaper.
I can't tell.
'Cause it's thick and wrinkly
and just dripping with black goo.
Don't want that.
Oh! It's this, yeah!
I mean, every time these
Doritos shells show up,
I'm just happy.
Dorito cheesy gordita crunch nacho cheese.
They put every word in that.
Oh, it's that thing, but not nacho'd.
Once you have the Doritos shell version,
to go back is like, no way. No way!
I've touched the sky.
I can stay on the ground no longer.
And then we have two
Crunchwrap Supreme options,
black bean Crunchwrap Supreme,
and then the regular Crunchwrap Supreme
is, of course, filled with beef.
OK, it's time now for India's sides menu,
starting off with Mexican corn salad.
You don't need to add so much sauce to it.
I feel like this could've
been a lot simpler,
and people would appreciate it more.
Next up, we have loaded
fries and loaded nachos.
So, typically, Taco Bell
does not serve loaded nachos
and loaded fries here in India,
but we found a restaurant
that was kind enough
to send it to us anyways.
I will say, this is
probably my favorite thing
about Taco Bell in India.
The loaded nachos are banging,
when you get them at the restaurant.
Oy.
But, yeah, there's a reason
they don't deliver it.
That tastes like wet cardboard.
And now we have two barf bags.
Just kidding.
Chicken nachos.
They had chicken tacos, and
now there are chicken nachos.
And our second doggy bag has -- whoa!
That was alarming. Because
what I saw was this.
I did not expect this
to come out of that bag.
Crispy chicken strips.
Sides, baby.
We got 'em.
Cheesy fiesta potatoes.
There's better things
to be had on the menu,
but I do like those.
Black beans, black beans and rice,
and you can get a guacamole side.
Now, here are some
items that are available
both in India and the US
but are still very different.
For example,
this is India's quesadilla,
grilled cheese quesadilla.
But as you can see,
it's filled with a lot of fajita veggies,
it's got this special creamy sauce,
and it's topped with a lot of jalapeños.
Whereas in the US, it
comes with just cheese.
How boring is that?
Correct. And this is what it looks like.
Incredibly boring.
Another big difference is here in India,
our nachos are all seasoned,
so they already have a masala
or some sort of spice to them.
Our nacho chips in the US are
just regular tortilla chips
with nacho cheese.
Here in India, in our veg options,
we use pinto beans, or rajma.
Whereas in the US, our bean
of choice is the black bean.
Exclusive US sauces.
Hey, you know what that means.
Sauce talk.
It's now time for
India's exclusive sauces.
We have quite the wide range.
We have cool ranch.
Because there's a lot of spice
in a lot of these burritos and tacos,
I imagine if you're somebody
who can't tolerate spice,
definitely get a side of this.
Then there is spicy salsa.
I tasted it. It's really nice.
It's got a lot more spice to it,
but also the flavor of
imli, which is tamarind.
We use it in a lot of our dishes,
especially South Indian dishes.
Then there's a chocolate sauce,
which I imagine is for churros
or some sort of dippable dessert.
But if you want to dip
your quesadilla into this,
I'm not going to judge.
Next up we have lava sauce,
which doesn't really
look as much like lava,
but it definitely has a kick to it.
Chicken tikka masala sauce,
which looks more like lava.
Down in the end here we
got reduced-fat sour cream.
Who doesn't like chips
and sour cream, right?
Could use some fat.
Then, moving on, we have a chipotle sauce.
Chipotle sauce is very good.
Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm.
Avocado ranch.
Mm!
I love it. More of that, please.
And they have a spicy ranch.
How spicy could it be?
Not very.
And finally, the red sauce.
OK, it is finally dessert time.
I've eaten a lot of savory food,
and I'm excited for the desserts.
Good old churros.
I am a big fan of churros.
They send you one chocolaty dip.
I feel like you can't
really go wrong with churros
if you want to call yourself a restaurant.
And next is something I
have never seen before.
Cinnamon twisties.
I could see myself, you
know, at 3 a.m. in the night,
sad, vulnerable, eating
a whole packet of these.
So that means it's a good dessert.
Taco Bell used to sell quesadillas
filled with chocolate, and
they were called chocodillas.
But I guess they've stopped that now.
Taco Bell is against puns.
The only US exclusive
dessert we have are these,
the Cinnabon Delights.
As Cinnabons, I'm pretty
sure this is filled
with some sort of cream cheese, right?
I assure you there's cream cheese in this
or whatever, their frosting.
Someone's got to eat it. That
definitely can't go to waste.
Eat it now!
Right? They're fantastic.
All right, it's time for
India's exclusive drinks.
What could we do without them?
Nothing. I would've choked to death
on all that burrito maida wrap.
First up, the soft drinks that we have,
we sell 7Up and Mirinda over here,
but actually in Bengaluru
I've seen a lot more variety of drinks.
So I think it varies from store to store.
Next up, Taco Bell sells juices.
This one was a mixed fruit juice,
but I drank it all,
and I can tell you, it was pretty good.
They also sell a
cranberry and apple juice,
but the stores that we asked in Mumbai
did not have those available.
And finally, they sell milkshakes.
This is mango. This is
chocolate. Cookie crumble.
The true test of a milkshake
is to test the fruit one
and see if it's still fresh.
Hey, that's pretty good.
The mango milkshake.
US exclusive drinks.
There's literally a million,
yes, really, of soft drinks
you can get at Taco Bell
you can't get in India.
So I just went and got a diet Pepsi
and, of course,
[clown horn honking]
Baja Blast.
After doing this, what, three,
four times at this point,
I'm actually starting to like Baja Blast.
You can actually get a
whole bunch of soft drinks
at the US Taco Bell.
♪ All of these ♪
I wasn't getting 20 drinks.
Get yourself a bottle, OJ, Tropicana.
Also something you can get
are things called freezes,
which at one point were frozen
slushy- or Slurpee-like drinks.
You can get, of course, a
Mountain Dew Baja Blast.
And also get yourself wild cherry freeze.
Oh, f---.
That's cough syrup.
Also, you can get coffee,
both iced and hot.
Iced coffee.
Oh, no, wait, that's soda. What is this?
Ignore that. Put that over there.
The Cinnabon Delight coffee.
OK, so they accidentally
gave us two of these.
Iced coffee that's flavored
like the Cinnabon Delights.
Are you kidding me?
I can just feel my life expectancy
just getting closer and closer.
Just like, sip, mm,
he ain't seeing his 80s, mm.
But it's worth it. That's delicious.
You can also get those coffees hot.
Taco Bell breakfast, baby.
I think this is just about everything.
Once again, I can't tell what anything is.
It's all just a sea of beige.
Let's find out together.
This one just says bacon.
Thank you for that.
Burrito with bacon.
I'm like the Riddler over here.
Just like, hey, figure it out.
Question mark, question mark.
I mean, it's a bit unnatural
how yellow that is.
It's really bright. It's a bit concerning.
This one's going to be the
one with steak, I assume.
Yeah. [laughs] Who's hungry?
The steak's a little weird.
Maybe don't get the
steak one specifically.
Do you see this condensation?
How bad this food is sweating?
Breakfast Crunchwrap Supreme.
Oh, there's sausage inside of this.
Look, comes inside.
It's like the magic ticket.
Now I get to work at
Taco Bell or something.
Their sausage is good, though.
Get yourself a hash brown.
They also have breakfast salsa,
but the Taco Bell I went
to did not have any.
Let's talk about nutrition,
everybody's favorite topic.
That's why you come to "Food Wars,"
'cause you love fast food,
but mainly, you love nutrition.
In India, a typical soft-shell
Mexican chicken taco
will be 185 calories.
In the US, our standard chicken
soft taco is 160 calories.
So we have fewer calories,
fat, carbs, and sodium,
but more protein.
Next up is the chicken quesadilla.
Ours has 268.5 calories.
And ours is 510 calories.
Now, please note the sodium
level on our quesadilla.
It's over half the daily
recommended amount.
That's a salty quesadilla.
In India, a vegstar
wrap is 239.9 calories.
Closest we have to that is our
black bean Crunchwrap Supreme.
Again, double the calorie count,
get a load of that sodium.
Are you looking for the most
calorific item here in India?
Well, look no further
than the cinnamon twists!
Each of these packets will
cost you 480.9 calories!
Here in the US, if
you're having a hard time
finding calories at a
Taco Bell, check out this.
The double beef grilled cheese burrito.
So, Taco Bell in India does not disclose
any of their ingredients,
but I thought it would be interesting
to talk about two of the ingredients
that we have here that
are unique to India.
No. 1 is paneer.
So, the problem with the Mexican paneer
that was served to me in
this batch of Taco Bell
is that it tasted like
the processed paneer you get at stores.
It tasted like something that
had been stored in the fridge.
Also, because paneer is
so popular here in India,
every single fast-food
restaurant has paneer options.
You know, when you know
how well it can be done,
I didn't like the paneer that much
in the burritos and tacos I had today.
The next ingredient I want to
talk about is tikka masala.
I thought it was OK.
It had a lot of flavor.
It was quite spicy.
But the thing that makes
tikka masala so exciting
is that it's always made
from fresh tomatoes.
And so you can sort of
tell there's a difference
when it's in the sauce form.
However, I will say it's
always a valiant effort
to see these fast-food companies
and people who come here
from abroad in general
adapt to the Indian palate
and try to make cuisine that matches ours.
In the US, we do disclose our ingredients,
and here's a few you should be wary of.
First is brominated
vegetable oil, aka BVO.
BVO is an emulsifier found
in citrus-flavored sodas
that specifically use citrus oils,
and it's considered a health risk
when ingested in large amounts.
In one case, a man who drank
2 to 4 liters of BVO soda per day
developed bromism and experienced symptoms
such as memory loss and
extreme muscle fatigue.
It can be found in the
ingredients of three
of the cantina-menu freezes:
the beach berry freeze,
the ginger mule freeze,
and the party punch freeze.
The last one, the party punch freeze,
also contains yellow
No. 5, aka tartrazine,
which is subject to
restriction outside the US
in places like the EU and India,
as it, quote, "may have an
adverse effect on activity
and attention in children."
And you can find it in
several Taco Bell menu items,
specifically the Doritos locos
taco nacho cheese shells,
oh, no! I had, like, three of those today.
And Baja Blast,
gah! Just when I was starting to like it.
I just want to shout
out Joe Avella and say
I understand what trauma
you must be going through
after doing so many Taco Bell episodes.
You're a brave, brave man, Joe.